[Music]
hello everybody
ladies and gentlemen yeah everybody's
excited about this from porno
and everybody's like porno all right
meanwhile meanwhile youtube is like
demonetized
porno is a shutter exclusive it was good
it's real good it's not an actual
affordable no it's a horror
it's about porn yes it's a horror comedy
and um it's about these
uh kids working in this
theater it's a christian theater they
come across damn porno tape
film and they put it on they stayed late
to work they put it on
and it turns out it's not really a porno
film it's a
it's an extra dimensional pouring up
and it summons a demon summons a
succubus
and they gotta fight us pretty much yeah
it's pretty cool
it's pretty cool it's funny funny funny
[ __ ] yeah i liked it a lot it wasn't
like as zany as i was expecting it was
like the the humor was a lot more
low-key but i liked that better
i kind of like along the lines of bill
and ted's bill and ted won maybe
yeah something like that maybe not that
zany and the pr yeah it's not that thing
not bad
the premise of it reminds me of uh
demons
the lumberto bava movie about like the
movie and it made everybody in the
theater like turn into like zombies or
whatever
yeah but it doesn't have it nothing
there's nothing like that
it's funny because this group of kids
that are working in here
they're like they're all so cute like i
love all their personalities you know
yeah they're all cool
this is actually set in the early 90s
because
the the movie theater it's run by like
the dude that manages it is like a big
uber christian and i guess like all the
teenagers that work there are also kind
of like
christians because they're all kind of
like you know grouper christianity
yeah the girl isn't that much into it
really she's like
they say crazy [ __ ] they say this the
same crazy [ __ ] that they really did say
back in the 90s and the 80s
yeah it's like a privately owned theater
and dude's a christian and he's hired
nothing but christians to work in there
and they have a lot of you know growing
up the christian military academy you
know as a young kid they had a lot of
the same kind of
crazy misconceptions about [ __ ] you know
well yeah they seem just
like naive but not like not like in an
obnoxious way just like in a kind of oh
kind of way they're just like you know
we got to resist the power that
pornography
and then dude [ __ ] one dude going on
and on about all his [ __ ] heavy
addictions and all his sins and [ __ ]
turns out it was just he smoked
cigarette yeah and they're like they
make it like a big deal out of it well
because his that character who's the
projectionist
they call him heavy metal jeff but he
gets really mad about it because like
it's not heavy metal it's hardcore yeah
he likes hard
and he has the the x's on his hands i
was like oh he's straight edge it's like
so i don't know if kids nowadays would
know what that is
a bunch of stuff from the 80s and 90s
you know what it is but i know what it
is because i think this movie
is set in because the two movies that
we're showing in the theater where they
worked were encino man
and a league of their own that's 1992
right yeah
i think it's 1992 1991. so these kids
would have been the same age as me
in that year yeah you know what i mean
because i graduated from high school in
1990. what was funny what was funny
about the straight edge kid is that
he had long hair and from what i
remember all the straight hedge kids all
had shaved heads
mostly not all i knew a couple that
weren't but i knew some girls man they
were cute girls that were straight edged
they hadn't seen the shaved heads or
chelseas which is just shaved head with
just bangs
yeah it was cute they were no those
little nylon flight jackets
yeah doc martens they'd be like the
flight jacks would be like maroon
maroon flight jackets with the [ __ ]
maroon dog martin
you know ox blood boots and uh super
tight jeans or
bdu jeans and [ __ ] you know what i mean
and
they were tripped they looked they were
cute yeah yeah i remember how it was
kind of like punk rocker yeah i was i
knew some people like that as well
so it's just it was so it was very funny
because this was kind of like even
though obviously it's you know it's a
2019-2020 movie yeah um
but it is set during that time period
and they really kind of got it right
like for that time but like i didn't
grow up like a christian or anything but
it's like i knew some people like that
so it's like
and and i like jargon was correct yeah
yeah so
i liked that they did that so so these
kids and like i said they're not
i like that it's funny but it's not
they're not like making fun of these
kids or they're not anything like that
it's just
they're they're very yeah they're very
naive but like i said it's not
done for laughs necessarily like it is
but you're kind of like laughing with
them not at them kind of i do
well a lot of the naive [ __ ] they were
they were saying was just
being 18 and 19. that's just that's you
know true
and being middle class that's just the
kind of [ __ ] you would believe back then
it's pre-internet yeah a lot of the [ __ ]
that they were believing in
they got right off of daytime television
shows and talk shows
yeah maury povich and [ __ ] yeah and you
could definitely so
they really so they really did like get
the the time period right
time period right yeah but um but yeah
so this
reminded me a little bit not only of
demons but also reminded me
slightly any kind of like cursed movie
type of thing like antrum or anything
like that which we just
covered not too long ago but i have to
say even though the movie is called
porno
the movie that they actually find like
what ends up happening is they're
they're staying late they're closing up
and the manager is like well i have to
leave for a couple hours but
um you know i'll come back at midnight
and and everything and then you can
guys can go home but he's like if you
finish
up cleaning all the uh theaters then you
can watch whatever movie you want now
there are only two movies playing
because they didn't have multiplexes
back then really
i mean they did but it wasn't as
widespread so
it ends up that this dude like comes
into the theater and is acting all crazy
and they just think he's a drunk or
something
and then he like crashes through a wall
or something like that was just kind of
had a curtain over and [ __ ]
and they find this whole other like sub
basement that has like all of these
other movies
and they find this movie that has like a
weird like symbol on it and so they
watch it
and it's just funny because the movie
that they're showing it looks like
because one of them like leans over the
other he's like is this an art film and
he's like i don't know
what i mean it is not a porn movie it
looks like a dancing video if you ask me
it looks like a dancing video without
dancing but the girls
yeah because it had nudity you know it's
like you there's
tits and bush and stuff in it but it was
just more like a like you said it's like
a dancing like a dance
it looked like that but i guess like it
she's supposed to be a sex demon right
or like a
suckabuse yeah she's a succubus so uh
yeah so it kind of unleashes her so they
have to like
fight against this movie's got some
[ __ ] badass um
practical special effects this is the
first time in a movie i ever saw
dude's balls explode his his nuts blow
up
and his gay buddy fixes it ties him up
yeah i i really really like that all the
violence in here is pretty much all
dick centered yeah and the dudes you
don't see that
the dude spends the rest of the movie
walking real slow
with his nuts blowing up it's [ __ ]
good man that looks really really really
funny
this isn't like a super gory movie or
anything um a lot of it is actually just
character work and a lot of them
you know kind of like interacting with
each other and creeping around like
looking for this demon or trying to
figure out what's going on
um so it's so don't think of it as just
like this like you know
gore minute kind of like zany whack it's
not like that
um it's just kind of it's kind of like
low-key but when they do
that stuff like that one scene like with
the balls was just
i was just like woo they went there okay
they're just showing it right there and
it looked like really really realistic
oh
the acting's good the storytelling's
good they said it in a
i guess it's probably an abandoned movie
theater that they found it
everything looks because it looks like a
period from that time period
it looks good and uh the acting is good
[ __ ] casting is really good
uh one of the main characters is this
girl she kind of carries you through the
movie she
she's pretty cool she's cute and there's
this [ __ ] the dude was praying over
once one time and he said what he said
something about um
oh lord lord or what is this this is not
this is not
what is it about her mascara wasn't
enough to conceal her lo her love for
the lord yeah her
[ __ ] like that she yeah what yeah you
know
because she was like kind of a 90s style
sort of
quasi-goth yeah yeah just she had thick
eyeliner on you know and
listen to the cure her boss was like you
know don't be fooled by the eyeliner
she's like what the [ __ ] is this
it's looking funny yeah it's like i
really i thought it was really
entertaining like
like i watched like a couple other uh
reviews of it it seems
i think it's got four or five skulls on
shutter i watched a couple reviews
there's not a
huge amount of reviews of it but um a
lot of people liked it but thought it
was like
too slow or something like that but i
didn't really find that um
because i liked the characters i thought
they were like really charming so i kind
of liked
like all their interactions and stuff
you could tell who wrote it and directed
it with somebody our age
yeah probably had to be yeah somebody
that was that age during that time
yeah because they got they got the the
dialogue and the culture of the time
right that's that's that's kind of how
it was i mean i laughed at the straight
edge guy
the straight edge guy was probably my
favorite although they were all they
were all like really funny
yeah that's the way that's where the
suburbs were yeah
yeah yeah and they were like even if you
weren't even if you weren't religious it
was still
kind of like that yeah it kind of was
yeah the religion didn't
didn't really change it that much it
just added more funny [ __ ] that they
believed it
they were more they were more shocked
when [ __ ] perverted [ __ ] happened
that they were calling each other
perverts for certain things
[Laughter]
a lot of misunderstandings
[Laughter]
yeah like i said i liked that they i
liked that angle that that they were all
like
these kind of like just naive christian
kids and like they didn't really they'd
never seen any real porn or
right yeah anything like that they
didn't really know what to make of it
like when they found this weird movie
like unleash the sex demon and they
didn't like really know how to do
like what yeah about it and like uh one
of one of them was the uh
was a gay kid who he he he prayed the
gay away they sent him to pray
particularly they sent him to the pray
the gay away campaign yeah
and he prayed to gayway evidently well
well not very successful i
don't think he thought he did
yeah but that's what they always think
you just gotta say
i i liked that he was kind of like just
he kept like making up a girlfriend that
he had yeah making a girlfriend not even
like from canada but that's yeah
and the girl that was there was into him
yeah she was yeah she was like
he's a good-looking guy so she's just
like oh and she
had some fantasy of him in his [ __ ]
baseball outfit
[Laughter]
he tries to battle the demon by [ __ ]
doing a [ __ ] nude dance she's
watching
pretending like she's not into it and
[ __ ]
the demon comes and gets him you just
got to see it man [ __ ] funny
yeah i really liked it i thought it was
really funny like i said don't expect it
to be like super zany like evil dead or
super gory or anything
it does have some like really good gore
effects like i said if you're squeamish
about
seeing like dicks and balls get [ __ ]
up then then you might not
be be too jazzed about this because like
i said pretty much all the violence in
here is directed toward penises
um which like that's kind of refreshing
you don't really see that much in movies
um but so yeah if that's if that's gonna
bother you you probably don't want to
watch it but
but like i said a lot of it is just kind
of like them interacting with each other
and like creeping around like this
creepy
uh you know movie theater i should add
too like just kind of on another topic
the same day that shutter added this
movie
which was yesterday i guess or the day
before they also added a huge like
mario baba collection i guess there was
like six or seven like mario baba films
there's like [ __ ]
bay of blood is on there black sabbath
is on there the whip in the body is on
there
um like just a [ __ ] ton of mario bombs
peninsula's going on there after i
bought it
yeah we just noticed that like peninsula
they're like oh coming soon we're like
god damn it we just bought that for 15
and we could have seen it for free yeah
oh well what are you gonna do we didn't
know
but yeah so uh anything else you would
like to add no that's it
this is a good movie you can you guys
probably like it yeah
i had a good time with it yeah you know
it's it's funny it was charming
and uh you know i liked all the
exploding balls and yeah you know that
was very funny
yeah because i was i was like when bad
things happen to male genitalia
i don't know why it's just very
entertaining to me it's all that [ __ ]
misogynistic [ __ ]
i guess it's just because so many horror
movies have like violence directed
toward women
so it's nice to see violence directed
toward men sometimes because you know
you don't see it as much yeah you don't
see it as much in horror movies
you see you see it sometimes but not as
often yeah um so i guess that's why i
find that
more entertaining yeah she looks like
something like i said it looked like
something out of a damn dancing movie
a dancing video yeah yeah if you guys
know what i'm talking about that's
probably where they
they probably got the idea because
that's around the same time period yeah
that was yeah that would have been right
around the side because they're like
yeah make it look like kind of a
something out of dancing yeah that's you
know okay yeah
but yeah so uh if you have shutter check
it out and like i said you can also have
like a whole [ __ ]
uh all-day marathon of mario baba movies
too if you're
into that which i'm kind of excited
about that because i've seen most of his
movies but they added a couple that i
hadn't seen so i'm kind of
i'll probably watch those over the next
couple days
and if you're in the united states
everybody have a really good
thanksgiving tomorrow that's right tom
tom got [ __ ] to do
tom got [ __ ] to do some got [ __ ] to do
we got well i did some of the cooking
got pies
the pies we got the did some of the did
i got all the damn
onions and celery pre-cooked for that's
for the for the stuffing well all that
yeah that all that cornbread or whatever
that is you already did
cornbread's made yeah yeah so we're
gonna stuff our faces tomorrow
yeah so uh cornbread stuffing yeah hell
yeah we already like busted into one of
the pies today because we just couldn't
wait
that's a pecan pie earlier but yeah so
have a happy thanksgiving everybody
and we will see you again live on
saturday
and we're gonna go back to another true
crime topic uh that should be
entertaining
so we'll see you guys then and bye